ciao a tutti sono molto felice intanto
di essere con voi e mi piace molto
l'idea di poter parlare il talento
perché tutta la mia vita è la ricerca
del 30 il talento che io non ho ma che a
cercare nelle altre persone definire che
cos'è un talento non è semplice
sicuramente
intanto il talento essere unici il
talento è avere un qualche cosa di
particolare qualcosa di particolare che
abbiamo tutti io questo lo voglio dire
lo voglio la voglio proprio vedere come
premessa perché tutti abbiamo un talento
un talento che però dobbiamo imparare ad
ascoltare
dobbiamo imparare a definire qual è il
nostro talento perché solo definendo in
modo chiaro in modo onesto franco a
volte anche crudele qual è il nostro
talento e quale non è il nostro talento
riusciremo a far diventare del nostro
talento un mestiere una professione di
vivere magari di questo talento
la prima cosa importante che stiamo
parlando già di un primo talento un
talento che dovremo sviluppare tutti e
l'ascolto di ascolto degli altri perché
ascoltando gli altri si impara
moltissimo
ascoltando gli altri si trovano le
risposte ascoltando gli altri è tutto
molto più semplice perché la metà del
lavoro è già fatto che poi ascoltare noi
stessi ascoltare intanto quali sono le
nostre vere aspirazioni ascoltare quali
sono le nostre vere volontà e poi
provare a mettere al servizio di questo
talento che abbiamo un esempio io potrei
avere il desiderio e la voglia di fare
il cantante o di fare il calciatore o di
fare il medico chirurgo magari amo da
morire uno di queste una di queste
professioni è il sogno della mia vita
diventare il più bravo cantante del
mondo diventare il miglior chirurgo
diventare il miglior pittore ma non ho
il talento per farlo diventare proprio
una professione perché c'è una grande
differenza tra passione e talento solo
ascoltando noi stessi ed essendo
autocritici ci potremo rendere conto se
abbiamo abbastanza baretto per diventare
per esempio appunto grande artista
la cosa che io consiglio sempre a tutti
ai tanti ragazzi con i quali parlo ad
esempio è anche quella di essere
talmente rigorosi con noi stessi di
essere talmente in ascolto di noi stessi
nel renderci conto che magari noi
potremmo avere una grande passione per
una verona per un ambito per un campo ma
non il talento per essere diciamo per
essere il
il cantante ad esempio nella musica o il
professore il primario però ci sono
tanti mestieri
ci sono tanti aspetti differenti che ci
potrebbero dare magari un mestiere un
impiego un lavoro nell'ambito che
l'unica mia esempio voglio fare il
cantante non sarò mai
beyoncé non sarò mai
vasco rossi perché mi rendo conto di non
avere quel talento però potrei lavorare
comunque nell'ambito della musica perché
potrei avere un talento per essere che
ne so un ottimo produttore un
arrangiatore un discografico un manager
musicale un corista un impresario e
quindi organizzare concerti ci sono
tante le professionalità dove applicare
il proprio talento del modo giusto e che
ci possono tenere legati al nostro mondo
al mondo che amiamo
l'importante è impegnarsi per stare il
più possibile attaccati a quello che ci
interessa quello che ci rende felici a
quello che è il mondo che noi vorremmo
vivere
per questo io ribadisco ancora una volta
avere talento significa sì essere unici
ma anche essere in ascolto il talento
io l'ho l'ho sempre cercato e penso che
non sia così difficile da annusare da
fiutare da da da scovare
perché il talento si manifesta in modo
anche fisico si manifesta in un modo
talmente evidente a volte che non è
individuarlo il talento possono sembrare
parole magari vuote ma non lo sono
veramente talento e la passione è quella
luce che si accende negli occhi il
talento e anche carisma ognuno nella
propria professione lo ribadisco non
solamente nelle professioni artistiche
il talento quando c'è si manifesta e
quindi io quello che vi consiglio di
fare in modo particolare è quello di
fare davvero quello che sentite di fare
veramente quello che vi appassiona ma di
farlo
applicando quelle che sono le vostre
possibilità alle vostre capacità a quel
mondo
io a moltissimo raccontare le storie di
tanti come me che avrebbero avuto un
sogno un desiderio magari di essere un
artista e che non sono non avevano il
talento per diventare artisti ma che
comunque hanno fatto della loro vita una
vita felice anche di ottime
soddisfazioni professionali vivendo il
mondo che avrebbero sempre voluto vivere
il talento è anche quello di sapersi
circondare delle persone giuste il
talento è quello di sapere fare team di
sapere fare squadra perché ricordatevi
che tutto quello che può mancare a voi
in qualsiasi ambito
lo potete completare con
la squadra giusta per cui talento loreti
cercherà anche in chi vi circonda era e
ricordarvi che vi completate e diventate
a 100 per cento di successo con
soddisfazione proprio andando a cercare
in chi lavorerà con voi accanto a voi
quello che voi non avete non siate
egocentrici non siate egoisti nel modo
sbagliato perché essere cocente ci può
essere anche un pregio nel momento in
cui non si diventa ciecamente
egocentrici cercate di usare il talento
altrui per arrivare al vostro obiettivo
l'ho ripreso ancora onta avere talento
significa essere nel nostro modo ognuno
di noi unici quindi lavorate c
cercate di studiare di approfondire di
esaminare tutto quello che vi si pone
davanti come possibilità e godetevi una
vita che prima di tutto vi renda felici
nel fare quello che più desiderate
anche se le felice un talento che ve lo
meritate tutti ciao e grazie di avermi
ospitato sono molto felice di essere
stato amore grazie